yesterday President Trump announced that
he would become the first president in
American history to attend and address
the March for Life which is taking place
as we speak we will examine how a man
who once called himself quote very
pro-choice became the most pro-life
president in American history
then Democrat impeachment manager Adam
Schiff accidentally explains why
Democrats are so eager to oust Trump
before November as the impeachment trial
enters its agonizing second day and
Tulsi gabbard's sues Hillary Clinton for
defamation because we are living in the
greatest time line finally the mailbag
all that and more I'm Michael Knowles
and this is the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
what a great day it's the March for Life
this is gonna be a huge I'll use huge as
a trump word demonstration for life and
for the preborn in Washington DC and
speaking of the president he will become
the first president to attend and
address the March for Life the march for
life began in 1974 that was the year
after roe v-- wade was decided and
invented the fictitious constitutional
right to kill your own child in the womb
and the March for Life has exploded in
recent years I mean it is just they call
it the pro-life generation I used to
think that was wishful thinking it's not
every year more and more people show up
to the March for life and yet for some
reason no US president has ever attended
it's been going on since 1974 you've had
a lot of Republican presidents since
then you had Richard Nixon didn't attend
Jerry Ford didn't attend you had the
Democrat Jimmy Carter but you gotta
remember Jimmy Carter was a very
Christian evangelical right he was a
social conservative in some ways
Democrat he didn't show up Ronald Reagan
the great conservative president he
didn't show up
Bill Clinton no surprise there Bush one
knows I'm not really a surprise there he
and his family had supported Planned
Parenthood at least in the past then by
the time he became vice president for
Reagan he he came around to the pro-life
side George W Bush was a very pro-life
candidate he did not attend the march
for life Barack Obama obviously did not
attend not until we got to President
Donald Trump do you have a president
attending the March for life and this is
very ironic because of all those
candidates President Trump in the past
may have been the most outspoken in his
support of abortion when when President
Trump was considering running for
president on the Reform Party ticket in
the late 90s he did an interview with
NBC's Tim Russert in which he described
himself as a very pro-choice here is
then potential candidate Trump partial
birth abortion the eliminating of
bortion in the third trimester big issue
in Washington would president Trump ban
partial-birth abortion I hate it I hate
everything it stands for I cringe when I
listen to people debating the subject
but you still I just believe in choice
and again it may be a little bit of a
New York background because there is
some different attitude in different
parts of the country and you know I was
raised in New York and grew up and work
and everything else in New York City but
I am strongly for choice and yet I hate
the concept of abortion but you would
not ban it no keep in mind by the way
they're not talking about abortion in
the first trimester here or the second
trimester they're talking about late
term partial birth abortion this is when
the baby looks exactly like a baby and
you kill it as he's coming out of his
mother's womb and President Trump says I
would have kept that legal that is a
very very pro-abortion position and yet
in the 90s it was a popular position and
look I come from New York I was in New
York in the 90s this was I think the
mainstream idea and actually it was a
former governor of New York Mario Cuomo
who came up with the excuse President
Trump is using there which is I
personally hate abortion but publicly I
support abortion on demand without
apology whenever you want so people
throw this in president Trump's face I
think the fact that Trump went from
being very pro-choice to the most
pro-life president ever illustrates a
central truth of the pro-life movement
we'll get to that in a second first I
got to thank our friends over at light
stream I have friends of mine family
members of mine who run huge credit card
balances or even if they're running
small credit card balances they're
paying huge interest rates don't do that
it is extremely dumb to throw that money
away I mean it is actually like setting
on fire when you're carrying these high
interest credit card balances you can
pay off those high interest credit card
balances and save money with a credit
card consolidation loan from light
stream and this is the key there are
absolutely no fees no fees I know you
don't believe that but no application
fee no origination
no transaction fee no prepayment
penalties no fees you right now if you
were carrying these high interest credit
card balances you are just throwing your
money away do not do it right now by the
way just for my listeners you can apply
now to get a special interest rate
discount the only way to get this
discount is to go to light stream
dot-com slash Knowles KN or wles you
know we all talk about being fiscal
conservatives over here we and just on a
personal level we don't want to throw
our money away well start that in your
own behavior start that at home let me
help you that is lig HT s TR e a m.com
slash Knolls KO wles light stream
dot-com slash Knowles subject to credit
approval rate includes 0.5% auto pay
discount terms and conditions apply and
offers her subject to change without
notice light stream calm / Knowles for
more information so president Trump in
the 90s says I'm very pro-choice I
support partial birth abortion as a
matter of the law and I hate it
personally but I support it politically
a lot of people held that view I know a
lot of people who held that view then he
changed his mind I think it is great
when people change their mind on the
question of abortion I once defended
abortion I for years when I was a
teenager when I was ignorant more
ignorant I defended abortion then I
realized abortion is indefensible so now
I'm pro-life it actually happened in
Washington DC I had a conversation with
a bioethicists who was a teacher of mine
in a summer program and she asked me my
views on abortion and I said I think
it's fine and I gave all these dumb
arguments and she shot down each and
every one of them and I I had my eyes
opened on the subject I'm not the only
one some of the most prominent voices in
support of abortion have flipped and
become some of the most prominent voices
in support of life when they examined
the evidence when they saw the reality
of abortion I'm talking about Norma
McCorvey
you might not recognize that name but
you would recognize her
sudonym which is Jane row the woman who
was used by opportunistic lawyers in Roe
versus Wade the case that 47 years ago
invented the fictional constitutional
right to abortion that woman became one
of the most prominent pro-life advocates
in the country she said that her
participation in Roe versus Wade her
allowing herself to be used by those
predator lawyers was the biggest regret
of her life how about dr. Bernard
Nathanson dr. Bernard Nathanson was the
founder of nay RAL that was the National
abortion rights League they've changed
what the letters mean over the years but
it remains the most prominent
pro-abortion advocacy organization in
the country I suppose other than Planned
Parenthood that guy co-founder of
Nairobi came a very prominent pro-life
advocate because he saw the reality of
abortion and he also exposed a lot of
the lies that the abortion industry
tells you like for instance they would
say before Roe vs. Wade
5000 women a year were dying from
back-alley abortions turns out that's
completely made-up as Bernard Nathanson
said that they plucked that number out
of thin air it just sounded good
actually when you look at the numbers
you're talking about a couple dozen or a
few dozen women who died from back-alley
abortions and as a just a percentage of
the abortion procedures done in states
where abortion was legal and where it
was illegal it was no less safe than
legal abortions at that time it was just
a complete lie peddled by the abortion
industry dr. Bernard Nathanson became a
huge pro-life advocate Abby Johnson Abby
Johnson is the focus of that movie
unplanned Abby Johnson worked for
Planned Parenthood she was being
promoted up the ranks then she saw the
reality of abortion now she is a major
pro-life advocate we have changed our
minds on that subject it's important to
be able to change your minds when new
evidence presents itself in every single
day the evidence becomes clearer on the
side of life you know if we were to just
lock ourselves in a box and just think
abstractly about abortion still the
arguments would be clearly on the side
of life
still they would all be against abortion
but if you just locked yourself in a box
and thought about it or had a
philosophical debate over a couple of
drinks with a friend maybe you could
rationalize the case for abortion it's
very easy to rationalize things right
but when you see a sonogram when you see
a 3d sonogram which now are ubiquitous a
virtually everybody can access them you
can see that it's not just a weird
little gray clump on a screen it's a
baby from very early on abortion and
virtually every single case stops a
beating heart now though these are not
exactly arguments I mean the argument
from fetal pain we just heard the other
day that babies as early as 13 weeks can
feel pain people used to think was 24 or
26 weeks those are not really arguments
I mean I don't think that the reason
that we shouldn't kill babies is because
they can feel pain I think the reason we
shouldn't kill babies is that they're
babies I don't think the reason we
shouldn't kill babies is because their
faces look pretty cute and they look
like a two-year-old baby's face I don't
care how ugly their faces are I don't
think you should kill babies because
they're babies but the arguments are not
enough they're insufficient you have to
see it as well a picture is worth a
thousand words and I think that's that's
what's happened to a lot of people who
have changed their minds and I can tell
you people change their minds on
pro-life because it's happened in my own
experience President Trump now has the
strongest pro-life record of any
president in American history most
importantly the judges he's appointed
textualist originalist conservative
judges judges who will who will push
back on the ridiculous invention of a
fictional right to abortion Trump
defunded Planned Parenthood to the tune
of 60 million dollars through title 10
now obviously Planned Parenthood
receives upwards of five hundred million
dollars from the federal government so
there's a long ways to go but he's he's
defunded over 10 percent of it through
the mechanisms of the executive branch
you would need the Congress to to defund
the rest of it he stopped taxpayer
funding for abortion of receives also
known as the Mexico City policy he-he-he
reinstituted that he has allowed states
to deprive Planned Parenthood of
Medicaid funds
he's defunded other pro-abortion
organizations and now
become the first president in US history
to attend and address the March for Life
that's a great record that is something
we should all get behind and you know
very often we hear critics of Trump on
the left and even some on the right a
sale president Trump's character I think
that record on pro life on a central
crucial issue and the issue literally of
life and death speaks very well of his
character and I think he deserves a lot
of credit for it I think it's courageous
I think there's there's a reason that
previous Republican presidents have not
gone as far as he has and I think we
should all tip our hats to him and thank
him for his great support of life other
people not so supportive of life for
instance at the New York Times there is
an op-ed by writer in The New York Times
just went up yesterday on the
anniversary of Roe versus Wade the title
is I'll never be ashamed of my abortion
just from the title something tells me
this author is protesting a little bit
too much something tells me the author
maybe does regret her abortion and she's
trying to insist that she doesn't but
let's see what she writes she says quote
I want my daughters to have the same
agency over their bodies as I did I'm
worried they won't I am a medium
brown-skinned neither rich neither rich
dark chocolate nor creamy cafe au lait
I'm a b-cup and have for a black girl a
barely there but I have flat feet and
oily skin and like so many American
women of reproductive age I've had an
abortion so obviously the first the
first part of that is completely
irrelevant the color of her skin and her
breast size and her butt and her feet
and her the oil on her skin none of that
is relevant what she's trying to say is
that these are all mundane sort of
trivial characteristics and likewise
I've had an abortion and that's also
irrelevant doesn't doesn't really matter
at all I think part of this too is to
check off some of the intersectional
boxes because the New York Times is
obsessed with racial and sexual identity
politics
but here's the money line right she says
I and I alone made the decision to
terminate a pregnancy more than a decade
ago so that I could be the best mother I
could be to the two children I already
had this doesn't make any sense killing
your children can never make you a good
mother I mean it's not possible I'm not
saying this woman as the devil that
she's the worst person ever she can
never be forgiven for her sins she could
be forgiven for her sins and she might
have other fine attributes but simply by
definition if you kill your children
that action cannot make you a better
mother being a mother means nurturing
your children if you kill them that is
the opposite of being a good mother now
this is an argument you often hear from
people they say look I want to decide
how many children I have so if I've
already got two children and then I get
pregnant I only want two children so I'm
gonna decide how many children I have
you lost the right to decide how many
children you have when you had another
child the issue here isn't when you're
gonna give birth or anything like that
you already have the child the only
question is do you kill the child do you
give the child away an adoption or do
you raise the child yourself if this
woman didn't want to raise another child
she could have just given it away for
adoption there are way way way more
couples in the United States who want to
adopt American children than there are
American children American babies out to
be adopted so she could have just done
that she didn't do that
she took the path of killing her child
it's a terrible thing I'm sure she faces
a lot of regret and a lot of shame about
that but that we hear this a lot from
people who were pro borsch and advocates
and then became pro-life advocates they
talked about the guilt and how they were
denying the guilt all the time so I
actually have a lot of pity for the
woman but she's lying when she said she
didn't have a choice she's lying when
she said it was about raising the
children she already had rather than
then having to raise another child and
she's lying about
killing children making you a good
mother it's just not possible in the
lies that that go along with Roe versus
Wade and abortion advocacy those lies
have such pernicious effects not just on
the individual not just on society but
on our whole legal system on our whole
politics we'll see how in a second the
impeachment fight that we're in right
now in many ways can be traced right
back to Roe versus Wade we'll get to
that in a second first I've got to thank
our friends over at Rock Auto I love
rockauto.com I like them from the very
beginning just because they're a family
business rockauto.com has been serving
auto parts customers online for 20 years
and when you think about the history of
online it's pretty much the whole time
you can go to rockauto.com to shop for
auto and body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers they've got everything
from engine control modules and brake
parts to tail lamps motor oil even new
carpet they've got it all what I really
like about Rock Auto is that even I can
understand this website because here's
what happens your car breaks down this
happened to me I guess now about five
six months ago car breaks down you go to
the auto body shop you said I need these
parts they never have the parts in they
just go online they order the parts and
then they charge you a huge markup you
don't need to do that you can go to
rockauto.com their catalog is so easy to
navigate you can figure out exactly
which parts you need for your car
whether that's your classic car maybe
that's your daily driver within just a
few clicks
you can check it out very easy to
navigate right now head on over to Rock
Auto dot-com you can find all the parts
available for your car truck most
importantly right Knowles Kanter wles in
there how did you hear about us box so
they can know that we sent you
rockauto.com aoc is pushing this kind of
nonsense
these incoherence arguments about
abortion she tweeted out yesterday with
regard to a visa issue from the Trump
administration Trump administration is
complicating visas for pregnant women
who are travelling here as as part of
the long-standing immigration fight
right but it includes now pregnant women
and she says pregnant women this
administration is now targeting pregnant
women when you single out the most
vulnerable the cruelty is the point
hashtag abolish ice hashtag breakup
Customs and Border Protection the most
vulnerable
why are pregnant women vulnerable how
are pregnant women vulnerable because
what the left has been telling us for
fifty years now is that pregnant women
are no different than you and me they've
just got a little clump of cells in them
you know I've got my appendix some
people have had their appendix removed
some people have a clump of cells a
fetus an embryo a zygote they say a
zygote is the very very first stage of
an embryo and the baby is a zygote for
about five seconds but they the the
pro-abortion people want to pretend that
it's just this little microscopic clump
of cells until a full nine months and
then a baby pops out all fresh that's
what they say it's totally it doesn't
matter it oh it's nothing has no human
dignity it's no different than a polyp
or a tumor or a parasite parasite that's
the word that they often use well okay
if it's just a it's just like a little
polyp or something or a little little
appendage that you don't need then why
are pregnant women vulnerable they
wouldn't be the reason pregnant women
are vulnerable is because they have a
new life forming inside of them that's
the reason why throughout most of this
country if you murder a pregnant woman
you're charged with double homicide now
it doesn't make a whole lot of sense
logically that if you murder a pregnant
woman you're charged with double
homicide but if that woman goes to the
Planned Parenthood clinic and kills her
own child that's all well and good and
actually it's a wonderful thing and you
should shout your abortion and never
regret it obviously those two things
can't be true at once and so to resolve
this this cognitive dissonance in New
York what they're doing is passing
radical abortion laws like the one they
they passed just a couple years ago
which changes the Penal Code and and
says if you murder a pregnant woman it's
not double homicide it's single homicide
they're trying to resolve this in their
heads but they're lagging in their
arguments so AOC fell into this trap she
said oh the pregnant women are so
vulnerable why are they vulnerable they
are only vulnerable if they've got a
baby inside of them and if they've got a
baby inside of them they should not be
able to kill it
Roe versus Wade has far worse
implications not just on our
argumentation on these stupid incoherent
arguments they've got terrible
implications for our politics they've
got terrible implications for our
government they've got terrible
implications you even for the
impeachment trial okay it's given us
division political uncertainty and
impeachment how how has Roe versus Wade
given us impeachment because so much now
of the presidential battles are about
the judges 2016 the single most
important issue in 2016 was the
replacement of Antonin Scalia on the
Supreme Court and the left wanted to
replace him with a left wing judge and
the right wanted to replace him with a
textualist judge the court was almost
perfectly balanced and so it really
mattered which way that was gonna swing
why do they care so much about the
courts time and again the left admits it
they say the reason that they care about
the courts is abortion is Roe vs. Wade
because there is no constitutional
argument for legal abortion everywhere
show me in the Constitution where James
Madison outlined the right to kill your
own child it simply does not exist and
now even left-wing legal scholars barely
pretend that that this exists often
they'll admit it doesn't exist but it
was very important for the Supreme Court
to to decide this to invent this legal
right to abortion well it's it's caused
a lot of division now it's it's caused a
lot of anxiety because we're no longer
arguing about what the Constitution says
we're no longer arguing about a
reasonable and objective interpretation
of the Constitution we're just arguing
about how to push our own personal
interests
you know Antonin Scalia I got to meet
him twice before he died which was
probably the coolest experience I've
ever had in politics and he had this
category
which was SBC he said certain things can
be stupid but constitutional certain
laws can be stupid but constitutional
the Constitution does not address every
problem not everything hateful or odious
or wonderful and beautiful is addressed
by some provision of the Constitution
and a key example of this would be
abortion the Constitution does not
outlaw abortion likewise the
Constitution does not create some legal
right to abortion it's simply not
addressed and it was a question left to
the states if the question had been left
to the states you might have seen a more
greater liberalization of abortion laws
and then I suspect his sonogram
technology got better you would probably
see a greater restriction on abortion
and probably New York would have
abortion and probably Alabama wouldn't
have abortion that would be a much
healthier state for the country we could
then go fight for pro-life in New York
specifically it would make it much
easier and you would have you would not
be in a situation where the left is so
desperate to maintain their right to
kill babies that they're willing to
throw out the duly elected president for
it
that is how deep the rot runs on
impeachment by the way we have a little
bit to cover on impeachment the the rot
of impeachment is spreading out to the
presidential race it's spreading out all
throughout the Senate and the media
aren't helping it either we will get to
that in just one moment we will get to
the greatest news story of the day Tulsi
Gabbard suing Hillary Clinton for
defamation that we will get to president
Trump's excellent comments on the
environment we will get to the mailbag
but first I have got to thank our
friends over at first leaf oh how I love
first leaf a sponsor near and dear to my
heart first leaf will send you excellent
wine why is often that you've never
heard about wines that you you wouldn't
have been able to pick out in a store
how do you get started so I got started
with firstly if I took a wine quiz to
assess my exact wine drinking
preferences whether that means sweetness
style how adventurous I am I put this
all into the computer right and so first
leaf takes that into consideration but
they also don't totally believe me
because I don't know I can't really
describe my palate that well so they
create this intruder
three six-pack of wine for me all for
just 2995 total this is six bottles of
wine for 2995 these wines usually sell
for at least $20 each they send it to me
and I tried them and I say okay well you
know that's a really good wine I really
really like that
that one no one's okay maybe I wouldn't
do any more of those it's fine and then
you go online and you rate them and
based on your ratings firstly it gets
much much more specific on your taste
and they start sending you the next
shipment look first leaf sends out more
than 17,000 unique shipments of wine
every month they know what they're doing
cuz everyone's tastes through different
I try this this second batch it's
unbelievable
so that's where my freebie was supposed
to run out but I couldn't give it up so
I now get this every month and it's
fabulous and I just love it and you're
gonna love it to sign up with my link
and you will get an exclusive intro all
for six bottles of wine for 2995 plus
free shipping go to try first leaf comm
slash Knowles six bottles of wine for
only twenty nine ninety five plus free
shipping at try first leaf comm slash
Knowles on to impeachment Joe Biden
thinks that impeachment is going to make
Trump harder to beat in November this is
according to comments he made at a
campaign stop just the other day many
people when they look at impeachment are
suggesting that Joe Biden is the great
beneficiary of impeachment right because
you've got Liz Warren Amy Klobuchar
Bernie Sanders are all stuck in the
Senate during the impeachment trial Joe
Biden is out there in Iowa campaigning
now we're something like 15 days out
from the Iowa caucus actually Joe Biden
might get hurt by impeachment this might
backfire on him because hungar Biden
might get dragged before the Senate you
know I'm doing a new podcast with Ted
Cruz that is coming out every single
night senator Cruz is going to leave the
capital after the impeachment trial head
on over to our studios here in
Washington DC and then he's going to
break down for us exactly what happened
last night and you can check this out on
the second episode a verdict with Ted
Cruz it's out now
senator Cruz pointed out that this all
might backfire the House Democrats may
have opened themselves up to a major
major problem for Joe Biden in the
impeachment so none of these Democratic
presidential can
it's are really doing very well here
nevertheless Adam Schiff who is the
leader of the House impeachment circus
he accidentally yesterday explained why
the Democrats are still really pushing
for impeachment he said the reason is
they just don't think they can win it in
November the president's misconduct
cannot be decided at the ballot box for
we cannot be assured that the vote will
be fairly won all right that's what he
says we can't be assured that the vote
would be legitimate we look if we took
we would take it to the ballot box but
you know then Trump might win and of
course he wouldn't win fairly I mean he
no Republican could ever ever win fairly
but still he might win and we can't take
that chance so we want to remove him
from office now before it's too late
give me a break shows you a little bit
about liberalism here the Harvard Law
Professor Adrienne berm you'll post
AddThis yesterday on Twitter
progressivism liberalism just assumes
that by definition it can never lose
fair and square
because progressivism says it there is a
clear path to progress there's a clear
place we're going if you stop progress
if you halt progress that is by
definition wrong and unjust and unfair
and so it's always got to be a stolen
election that's why Al Gore he couldn't
possibly have fairly lost in 2000 that's
why you wouldn't give up the the
election Hillary Clinton in 2016 same
thing she lost she lost the electoral
vote clearly and yet she refused to
concede the election for hours and hours
she wouldn't even show up on election
night it because it's not possible to
lose fair and square
according to progressivism the media
aren't helping this either they're
actually further confusing this a Joe
Lockhart who is a CNN contributor and
former press secretary for for President
Bill Clinton he posted on Twitter a
completely fabricated conversation
totally fabricated conversation he says
quote overheard convo between two
Republican senators who only watch Fox
News is this stuff real I haven't heard
any of this before I thought it was all
about a server if half the
stuff Schiff is saying is true we're up
shifts Creek let's say shift they cease
it a different word hope the White House
has exculpatory evidence that got eight
thousand retweets 31,000 likes on
Twitter then afterward Lockhart says
okay maybe I made up the convo but you
know exactly what they're thinking so he
just admits I totally made that up I was
totally fictitious that second tweet got
800 retweets and eight and a half
thousand likes there were an order of
magnitude more retweets to the fake news
then there was to the correction for the
admission that that was not true we've
got to get to Tulsi suing Hillary which
is just so so great we'll get to an
important line from Trump on the
environment and then we will get to the
mailbag but first before all of that
I've got to tell you about paint your
life which I absolutely love if you want
to give a meaningful gift go to paint
your life calm what is paint your life
you can have an original painting of
yourself your kids your family a place
that you all love a favorite pet you can
have an original painting made at a
price that you can afford and that's at
paint your life calm I want to be clear
this is not some computerized gimmick
this is a true painting done by hand by
a world-class artist all created from a
favorite photo makes the perfect gift
for any holiday I was a little skeptical
I didn't think you could get a really
good painting like this through an
online online vendor so for my
stepbrothers wedding I decided to try it
out on him I uploaded one of his wedding
photos you get to pick the artist you
get to work with the artist throughout
the process you get to see a bunch of
different updates if you don't love the
final painting your money is refunded so
I get the painting I look at it it's
absolutely beautiful absolutely
beautiful I mean unbelievable work and
I'm already planning to use them again
for more paintings it's just so so cool
right now is a limited time offer you
can get 30% off your painting that is
30% off three zero and free shipping to
get this special offer text michael mi
CH AE l to 64,000 you will not regret it
Michael 264 thousand texts mi CH AE l
264 thousand all right before we get
into the
I'll bag before we get into Telus II
before we get into a great environmental
speech the president Trump just gave
that no one's talking about I've gotta
say goodbye to Facebook in YouTube we
were talking about pro-life today
obviously for the anniversary of Roe vs.
Wade and for the March for Life
well the pro-abortion activists are
shouting their abortions on national TV
and referring to preborn babies as
parasites pro-lifers are fighting back
all of us here at the Daily wire have
spoken out for life last year ben
shapiro addressed a crowd of a hundred
thousand at the March for Life in
Washington DC our advertisers as a
result of those actions were targeted by
left-wing fake media watchdogs and
operatives and we lost a lot of revenue
from that this is a constant battle to
protect pro-life advocacy from the
forces of abortion another group that
has experienced this is a live-action
live-action is one of the most important
voices in the pro-life movement they
have helped to expose Planned Parenthood
and other abortion clinics for the
horrific crimes they commit pro-abortion
activists of targeted live-action and
censored them on social media platforms
when they don't succeed in kicking them
off altogether that's why our daily wire
members are so important your membership
helps keep our cameras on it keeps our
microphones turned up even when the left
is pressuring our sponsors you can keep
the pro-life message from being
cancelled from now until January 31st a
portion of any daily wire.com membership
will be donated to live action with the
promo code live action joined daily
wire.com make your pro-life voice heard
head on over we'll be right back with a
lot more
I don't know if you remember this but a
little while ago Hillary Clinton accused
Democratic presidential candidate Tulsi
Gabbard of being a Russian asset of
being a Russian stooge here's Hillary
Clinton I'm not making any predictions
but I think they've got their eye on
somebody who's currently in the
Democratic primary and are grooming her
to be the third-party candidate she's a
favorite of the Russians they have a
bunch of sites and BOTS and other ways
of supporting her so far they being
Vladimir Putin and the Russians and just
in case you were unclear of whether
she's really talking about tulsi gabbard
because Clinton doesn't refer to her by
name Hillary Clinton's spokesman came on
later was asked specifically are you
talking about Tulsi Gabbard and he
confirmed that in no uncertain terms he
said if the nesting doll fits okay so
now Tulsi GAD we're not gonna take it
lying down she's not gonna take it like
Jeffrey Epstein did reportedly you know
I don't I'm kidding or am i I don't know
Tulsi Gabbard is suing Hillary Clinton
for defamation over her remarks about
this this Russian asset accusation Tulsi
gabbard's lawyers are saying that
Clinton's comments smeared her political
and personal reputation quote Tulsi
Gabbard is a loyal American civil
servant who has also dedicated her life
to protecting the safety of all
Americans absolutely true you got to
remember Tulsi gabbard's put on a
uniform Tulsi Gabbard has served in the
US military the smear from Hillary was
totally expected when you look at the
Clintons political history but it was
still so so wrong I love that she's
fighting back this reminds me of the
Nick Sandman Covington kids lawsuit
against the press who baselessly smeared
them as racists and bigots for wearing a
mag ahead I wish Tulsi Gabbard very well
I don't think Tulsi Gabbard should ever
be president I don't think she should
get anywhere near the Oval Office but I
really really like that the infighting
among Democrats is now so intense that
you've got a presidential candidate
suing the former presidential nominee
for
millions and millions and millions of
dollars that is just too sweet before we
go I want to highlight something that
President Trump said at Davos he was at
the World Economic Forum group of all of
these kind of crazy Western elites
businessmen politicians they all gather
and talk about how wonderful they are
and why they should all run our lives
and President Trump was there he gave a
speech about how America's comeback and
how he got the last laugh here on the
World Economic Forum he also gave a
speech about the environment
environmentalism climate change hysteria
has become the most famous religious
issue of the left well left to speaks of
it in religious terms right they talk
about the end of days the world is all
ending in 12 years or 18 months if you
ask some some of those politicians and
public figures they talk about how you
need to confess your climate sins I mean
NBC News set up a website that was a
confessional for all of your sins
against the environment you can even buy
indulgences in the form of carbon tax
credit it has a full religious system to
it this environmentalism and president
Trump totally put the kibosh on it he
exposed it for what it was and he said
we are charting a different course in
America here's President Trump but to
embrace the possibilities of tomorrow we
must reject the perennial prophets of
doom and their predictions of the
apocalypse
they are the heirs of yesterday's
foolish fortune tellers and I have them
and you have them and we all have them
and they want to see us do badly but we
don't let that happen they predicted an
overpopulation crisis in the 1960s mass
starvation and the 70s and an end of oil
in the 1990s these alarmists always
demand the same thing absolute power to
dominate transform and control every
aspect of our lives we will never let
radical socialists destroy our economy
wreck our country or eradicate our
liberty America will always be the proud
strong and unyielding bastion of freedom
great great speech
encourage you to watch the whole thing
what Trump points out explicitly is that
these environmental doomsdayers always
get their predictions perfectly wrong
they oh they get their priorities
perfectly wrong and we see that today
you know the New York Times clamoring on
a daily basis with hysterical
predictions about global warming how we
have to stop using plastic straws or
else the world is going to end
hysterical stuff and in that very same
paper they'll talk about how we have to
kill babies and we should never regret
killing babies they cry they sob they
weep if you accidentally put too much
salt in the water for the delta smelt in
california they're they're so furious
there and they're ending their garments
if you use a plastic straw because
they're afraid of the Sun monster if you
put a little carbon dioxide into the air
if you cut down a tree they will cry and
they will celebrate when you kill a
million babies a year in the United
States alone they care more about the
rocks than about human beings this is
perennial with the left the left always
says they love humanity but they don't
seem to like individual humans all that
very much they don't seem to have a
whole lot of compassion for the
individual human whose life is about to
be snuffed out in his mother's womb
those are two completely opposite ways
of viewing the world one version in
which we prioritize trees and little
fish and rocks over human beings and one
in which we say man has inherent dignity
and we should respect that dignity and
we should take care of our environment
and so much as we're stewards of our
environment and in so much as that would
be pleasing and beneficial to human
beings do you want a worldview focused
on the trees and on the rocks or do you
want a worldview that that elevates and
respects human beings that's the choice
you got the left on one hand you got the
right on the other and the current
right-wing leader in the United States
President Trump is making that very
clear he's gonna make it clear today
March for Life let's get into the
mailbag in our remaining time from Jason
hi Michael a few months ago I definitely
made a mistake especially because I'm
Catholic resulting in my girlfriend's
pregnancy I think I know what mistake
you're talking about she and I are both
pro-life and despite being 17 and 18 I
know she won't abort the child about two
weeks after finding out she left me
wants nothing to do with me including
refusing to contact me and giving
updates about the child I'm graduated
not in college I'm currently working
into a decent financial lifestyle but
for all I know my ex could already have
an adoption plan set up I don't know
what advice do you have for me thanks
love the show Jason okay you're in a
tough spot I'm not gonna minimize that
obviously you it's it's very hard to
imagine that there's a perfect solution
to all of this however you should rest
easy you should lie back and relax you
should be so happy that you it does not
seem like you're gonna make this huge
mistake of killing your child that you
will regret for the rest of your life
and that your ex-girlfriend will regret
for the rest of her life now you've got
to own your mistakes right you along
with pretty much every other teenager in
America had had some sexual experiences
before marriage right that happens all
the time you're not the only one that
that's happened to and there are
consequences for that one of the
consequences is your girlfriend gets
pregnant now I guess in a perfect world
you guys would get married and raise the
kid but maybe that's not gonna happen I
mean she's she's got the right not to
marry you she could do that that's one
of the risks you run with sex outside of
marriage now if she gives the child away
for adoption that's gonna take away a
lot of your rights if she decides to
raise the child herself you will very
likely have more rights so you'll have
to try to discuss that with her now she
might not want to talk to you right now
she might be under a lot of pressure I
suspect she is she's 17 years old and
she's pregnant so I would have some
empathy for her there or at least some
sympathy rather because she's in a an
emotionally very difficult spot and and
already you two have made
the single most important choice you can
which is not to kill the child if that
is all you get out of this and she gives
the child away for adoption or she
raises it on her own or she raises it
with a stepfather
you could still rest easy what I would
recommend is give her a little bit of
time
be respectful she's in just as much
stress as you are she's in probably a
lot more stress than you are and then
try to discuss what will happen into the
future and you need to be willing to
accept the prospect that your child is
is given away for adoption or if you
would prefer to raise the child yourself
you have to make that argument to her
you don't have a ton of rights in this
situation that's one of the consequences
of your actions and you'll have to live
with that but I think once the motion of
the situation has died down a little bit
you you may be able to speak this with
her you just have to do it respectfully
you have to do it responsibly
acknowledging that this is some of this
is your fault some of the the problems
that you're having here are are your
fault and you should do it with hope and
you should do it at least joyful in the
knowledge that your child is not going
to be killed from Joshua Michael as a
well dressed fellow yourself what are
your thoughts on the three-piece suit is
it too much for an attorney thanks for
your wisdom I love the three-piece suit
but it depends how you wear it you don't
want to end up in one of these my cousin
Vinnie kind of situations you look
ridiculous or like you some dandy from
the 19th century but if you if you wear
a modest three-piece suit that that
isn't you know wouldn't fit in on like
Liberace playing in Las Vegas or
something then I think it can work very
well when you wear the three-piece suit
I would recommend do not button the
jacket I think that the waistcoat being
buttoned and the jacket being open is a
much nicer look it's a little more
casual it's a little easier to pull off
today but I'm a big fan of it absolutely
go for it people dress like schlubs all
over this country you could bring a
little class from Dylan dear Michael do
you believe that the left has become so
radical that there were me
of Democrats who will vote for Trump in
2020 I always hear vote blue no matter
who yet I've seen people in my personal
life such as my mom who's a Democrat
stating that she will most likely vote
for Trump in 2020 just because have how
the Democrats have acted in the past
three to four years do you think she is
the exception or the norm thanks for
everything I think there are a lot of
Democrats who could vote for Trump his
Trump is not a normal Republican I mean
he's a guy who in the 90s said I'm very
very pro-choice cuz I'm from New York
right he's a guy who supported
Democratic politicians he's a guy who
talks differently than other Republicans
and he's a guy who on substantive policy
matters has behaved in a different way
from other Republicans in the way he
talks about economics in the way he
talks about trade deficits in the way he
talks about tariffs the way he talks
about foreign policy so certainly they
could get Democrats I think part of the
reason Democrats and normal left winger
and maybe that's a contradiction in
terms people who are typically left-wing
or could go over to the Republican side
this time is in part because of Trump he
is a unique candidate but I think in
part it's it's actually beyond these
practical political issues and it comes
down to things like Democrats won't
admit that there were only two
biological sexes Democrats had a whole
debate over LGBTQ issues in which they
pretended that men can be women who Leon
Castro a Democratic presidential
candidate endorsed abortion rights not
only for women but for men trans women
you know men who now pretend to be women
that's probably a little bit too far and
I think in particular in some of these
states that President front needs to win
some of the states that are going to
decide the election Wisconsin Michigan
Pennsylvania these are these are places
that are pretty normal you know they're
not as a radical as Los Angeles or New
York City and so those social questions
are really going to matter that
radicalism is not going to play very
well in those places and I think it
gives Trump a big advantage and it's
going to give them advantage by taking
votes from Democrats and centrist voters
and independent voters from Margo hey
Michael in light of your show the
from earlier this week about wanting
royalty without the responsibility I was
thinking that idea could also be
connected with abortion most of the time
abortion goes back to wanting the
pleasure of sex without the
responsibility of parenthood what are
your thoughts and is it possible to
convince leftists that taking
responsibility is a good thing keep the
great shows coming as you get closer to
500 episodes
thank you very much Margo yes of course
I mean of course people the reason you
have sex outside of marriage is because
you because sex is extremely fun and
marriage requires accountability and
responsibility and duty and obligation
and people want to have fun and they
don't want to want to lock themselves
down it's perfectly understandable
totally get it
however people are falling into a very
easy temptation which is to believe that
Duty is unpleasant that obligation is
unpleasant that if we were free from our
jobs and our obligations and the things
we have to do for our loved ones and our
families if we could just do whatever
the hell we wanted all day long we would
be so happy and live such a good life
and that is just BS the playwright
George Bernard Shaw said that hell is
the place where you've got nothing to do
but amuse yourself and that's true when
people don't have anything to do and
they don't have any obligations we don't
have any demands on them they get
depressed you know I waited for a long
time to get married I'm considering I
met my wife when we were like 10 years
old you know I waited until my late 20s
to get married because in this culture
especially where I come from New York I
live in Los Angeles I was just always
told oh don't get married until you're
in your 30s try not to get married until
you're 40 or even later that'll be so
much better you just focus only on you
and don't tie yourself down and don't
have any commitments and your life will
be a lot better and I realize that's
just completely untrue I wish I'd gotten
married earlier because you find meaning
in your life precisely through
obligation precisely through duty when
you just pursue your own desires and
appetites all day long that doesn't
leave you feeling very satisfied it's
actually insatiable
you're not going to fit thank gosh I
lived a great life I'm glad I did
whatever I wanted you actually find
meaning and
through obligation and duty and it's
always gonna be a temptation just to
pursue your own selfish desires but if
you want to live a good life and be
pleased with yourself in the end pleased
with how you lived it it's it's going to
be through responsibility and speaking
of meaning you know I'm I'm leaving you
now for the weekend this that we will be
back on the Michael knows show on Monday
but I'm not leaving you completely
without any content because we've got
the first episode out now of my new show
with Prager you it's called the book
club and the book that we will be
examining is man's search for meaning a
really important book so go check that
out that's by Viktor Frankl and it's
gonna be dennis prager and i discussing
that so you can find that at Prager U
and then I've got another show that is
going to be coming out every single
night now through impeachment which is
the Ted Cruz podcast verdict with Ted
Cruz I will be there joining the senator
every single night will be breaking down
impeachment that includes tonight and
tomorrow and every day that there is a
hearing on that and of course you can
check out the last few episodes of the
final season of another Kingdom this
three season long journey Andrew
Clayton's narrative podcast that I think
is just absolutely terrific stuff and
I'm so glad I had the privilege to read
it all these years so you can check that
out that's a lot of content for this
weekend
and if somehow you make it through all
that then I'll see you back here on
Monday I'm Michael Knowles this is the
Michael Knowles show see you soon
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Ben Davies director Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey supervising
producers Mathis Glover and Robert
Sterling technical producer
Austin Stephens assistant director pavel
madoski editor and associate producer
danny D'Amico audio mixer robin
Fenderson hair and makeup Jessa alvera
production assistants McKenna Waters and
Ryan love the Michael Noel's show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20 if you prefer facts over
feelings aren't offended by the brutal
truth and you can still laugh at the
insanity filling our national news cycle
well tune in to the Ben Shapiro show
we'll get a whole lot of that and much
more see you there